anything you guys buy in gta i will buy
for your mom how much money do you have
zero dollars zero dollars zero and i
have ten
thousand dollars in real life that you
guys can spend go out in the world of
gta
make money and whatever you buy i will
buy for your mom i love you mom
does it have to be legal you have to
make money through legal means if you
make the money illegally your mom gets
nothing chandler i'm pausing go
what are you doing i'm i'm marking my
map where'd my car go wait wait how's
the highest amount of damage to vehicles
and other players you get paid for this
oh wait that's not legal
not legal it's an illegal advantage
carl's already out his mom gets nothing
haha
wait i wanna hit this jump real quick i
know we need to make money but i also
gotta hit this jump can't you make money
off jumps
only one way to find out let us know
chris did you make any money off the
jump
i slammed onto the ground no i did not
make any money all right so let's look
at the map there's got to be something
that's
legal here come on baby come on baby i
got to get there quick
wait can i race people as long as it's
legal
it counts okay chris by talking about
your strategy out loud carl was able to
steal it
that is true i probably should not have
done that i found something really cool
that isn't cars racing at all and i'm
not gonna tell anybody what it is i know
what i'm going to do
i'm already on the way to it between me
and you how are you making money i'm
going to race rc cars for money and then
what are you going to do with that money
i'm going to take it to the casino and
put it all on black baby
all right chris i want to get my mama
car she wants an suv so i'm going to try
and get her suv
i'm going to a arm wrestle waypoint and
i'm going to arm wrestle for money carl
hello have you made any money yet zero
what would your mom say
that she doesn't love me all right well
go make some money i'm trying i'm going
to a racetrack let's say hypothetically
you win all 10 grand chandler what are
you buying your mom i'll probably put it
towards her personal business that she
just started all right we're gonna make
as much money as possible
thank you ma'am excuse me i'm just
borrowing your car i'll return it wait i
thought this is a race track but it's a
casino and i don't got money to gamble
yet
looks like you gotta make some money i
know a guy who
does business that is legal is it legal
it is legal and i'll explain it if i can
find it i accidentally got the cop
something that's illegal
all right i'm here baby i'm going to
monster trucking monster trucking
somebody join my arm wrestling game
oh wait nope this is the opposite of a
legibit legit business
i forgot this is a different mission
everybody get away from this area this
is a very non-legal way to make money
this clearly looks legal it has
government funding oh god
i didn't realize how many people would
be in this join the game
are you guys doing legitimate races i'm
doing a death race oh death race
death sounds illegal isn't death illegal
i will go investigate right now
yeah come on in water's fine jimmy so
this job right here
i'm doing a repo job you have to steal a
car but it's because they didn't pay
their bills
i'm limiting you to 500 on repo all
right all right what is this death race
nonsense it's in a stadium it's a
sponsored sporting event let me check
the weather
it's approved chandler how are you
making money well i tried to invite
chris to arm wrestle
and he did not accept we can arm wrestle
i didn't know that's what i'm tired of
yelling for you
jimmy i was filming content while you
were screaming at me
it's actually at war like we're fighting
each other oh war yeah that's legal
death and war the two most legal things
ever tell me this isn't legal this looks
extremely legal oh
god it's all legal
jeez you run somebody over and get the
cops on you i didn't mean to i'm not
trying to make money he's not making
money off of it i'm sorry mom
i'm getting in these fights i don't have
any wheels left i'm on the peak of
crying why chandler it's for my mom and
i can't do anything
oh that ain't illegal at all it's not no
no
i hired a sponsor it's good it has a
sponsor yeah
shooting people oh it's not illegal it's
not illegal we just died
is there shooting people no no no no no
no no no i think it's illegal i didn't
shoot a single person did you get any
money out of it um i made
two thousand five hundred day so you
have twenty five hundred dollars what do
you buy in your mom
i'm getting her 1 500 worth of clothing
and i know what you're thinking don't
you have another thousand
can you buy ice cream in this game see
mom i'm only getting you good thing
is it first to spend it yeah i should
secure this 2
500 spent of course and then go make
more of course but do it quick
oh i'm burning these fools oh
they all crash where do i go i'm in this
race and i'm not even on the track
oh there's no way i'm gonna beat this
i'm in a sedan
man this sedan is booking it
ow so i'm gonna spend two thousand five
hundred on clothing and then a thousand
on ice cream
oh there's no way i'm beating this time
trial time trial that's illegal
no it's not hey where can i buy ice
cream you wanna get your mom ice cream
not a car why would i get her a car he
only has a thousand bucks left
what car's a thousand dollars well
probably this one after i'm done with it
carl's actually buying his mom a
thousand dollars worth of ice cream oh i
mean that's fair
i want to try and get her something a
little better and healthier than ice
cream because my mom's lactose
intolerant
no i've been lapped oh excuse me what
happened to my wheel
i'm trying to get inside of this burger
shop if you spend 500
on burgers we'll give our 500 mcdonald's
gift card
man this is embarrassing lap 2 out of
ten
good god jello they better give you some
stacks i'm driving backwards with two
wheels
this is so sad why are my wheels gone
how do i end this event all right
we're doing this i'm doing open wheel
racing it's the only way i can find to
make money that's what i'm doing bro and
it's so hard
what are you doing on the pier i'm
looking for a place to get ice cream why
i don't understand where i can get ice
cream i forgot that if i can't think of
something to buy i can always check the
internet how do i buy these burritos
i made a purchase really i have to have
somewhere to store it buy your mom a
house please end the race
all right open wheel racing time if you
want to buy your mama car you have to
get a garage
oh no i literally needed to get a garage
for a freaking bmx bike
i got spun out wow oh i know what to get
yeah i'm getting my mom
costumes dude these people just keep
slamming him to me because they don't
know how to race
would you stop just slamming into me why
jimmy i dare you to guess how much money
the pig mask is 100
it's 965 to be exact that's one tenth of
the money we're spending in this video
do i do it it's a paper bag mask
i bought 20 worth of soda i'll add that
to the list of things to buy your mom
okay i'm gonna try to double the money
really quick
ah don't bump me there has to be a way
to make money without doing anything
illegal even in gta sorry mom
i'm having a hard time i'm trying my
best i know you always told me not to
gamble but mom it's just free money how
do i gamble
lucky wheel i'm just gonna do the lucky
wheel lucky wheel i'm going all in
wait can i make any money on this oh
twenty thousand oh
forty thousand let's see what we get
carl if you win
you could buy your mom some dub stuff oh
it was one away from 30 000 thank god
people are finishing the race
finally racing ends in eight seconds
thank god moment of truth chris
did not finish the race do i get money i
don't get any money from that oh my god
what a waste of time
everyone drop what you're doing carl
we've been going for over an
hour that's true and you guys have only
made 2 500
there's still 7 500 left for your moms
i'm trying
i am officially opening it up to illegal
activity make money by any means
all right now i can make some money now
that i can do illegal activities
i've never been illegal in my life i
don't know what to do illegal activities
remember first to spend it get it let me
out let me out
so what's your strategy carl i already
know what i'm doing and i don't want to
say it out loud but come with me jimmy
come on
three moms 7 500 on the line
mom i love you lamar stop calling me
yo i just got two grand for good
behavior wow jump up jump out of the car
jump out of the car
channel go spend it quick quick quick oh
my god the vehicle is too good
if lamar calls me one more time i'm
gonna have a fit
i'll get two grand for selling this we
gotta find a better car
one more shut up oh my god gta
and now i'm in a hood fight i don't know
why here we go zeon cabrio
six grand i just got six grand guys
hurry up and make money before carl
spins it give me your money
give me your money come on i need money
this is for my mama you understand we're
in difficult times
get out of the way lady i'm driving here
all right
a thousand dollars what do i spend it on
what do i spend it on what do i spend it
on almost a los santos customs
i got three stars for robbing that store
i guess because i shot the guy yeah i
think that comes with it
ow the cops are shooting me the clops
the cops
the quaps can i also rob this store even
though i have the cops on me
let's see give me your money guys carl's
about to spend six grand go go go
carl stop i'm dropped
this is the most frustrating game i've
ever played i hate it hey are you guys
listening
i just spent another three thousand
fifty five hundred dollars is gone
i'm gonna make my mom paid to get me a
haircut jimmy i got a 50
haircut this vehicle is worth 5800 baby
that's cool
i got 8 grand now what should i buy i
don't know if i buy
quick i'm about to buy another thing oh
this one's a big ticket item
oh oh i guess carl's just taking it off
for his mama that's
it guys what'd you buy what'd you buy
i'm spending twenty dollars for the
movies
i'm at the store wait is this a like a
a gas station all right vehicle sold
all right so i got 3 800 all right i'm
buying
clothes wait chandler let me get my mom
something jimmy how are you going to get
on the ferris wheel with me because
that's when i'm buying my mom
i bought my mom three thousand dollars
worth of clothes chandler's mama needs
to get something right
jayla what are you buying your mama i
bought my mom earrings
and that is all 10 000 spent you bought
your mom clothes you bought your mom
clothes you bought your mom yuri thank
you so much for watching hit that
subscribe button if you're not already
and we'll be sure to deliver all their
moms the things they bought don't forget
the coke zero